retournez moi je ne veux plus voir la
gauche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sachez que dans un instant vous allez
faire connaissance avec cette séquence
qui va s'appeler dcs verdez gilles
verdez ce soir il sera dans un fauteuil
comme dans the voice et il aura le droit
de se retourner que trois fois dans
l'émission pour donner son avis non il
peut poser que trois fois c'est bien il
faut pas qu'ils voient la cie buzz les
trois premières minutes il termine et on
voit plus
hu
pernikoff vous êtes le degré zéro de
l'analyse média phrase une connerie mais
vous n'avez rien compris
on suit en fout que vous aimiez
mélenchon ou pas c'est le documentaire
dont on tard vous l'avez vu le
documentaire
oui je vous l'avais vu par nicolas
pallois regarde il regarde plus
alors autant j'avais décroché totalement
de devaux et adultes autant là je me
suis repris au jeu alors il ya marqué
les enfants sont des enfants
moi je vois des enfants qui quelque part
réalisé un rêve se pense que se pose pas
la question de savoir si oui ou non un
jour eux aussi feront un indice pour ça
mais vous mais vous mais vous étiez le
premier a vilipendé ce programme est
alors que sa mère avait pas ce que cyril
en dit du bien maintenant vous lécher ce
programme mais c'est scandaleux ce
programme castaldi vous savez très bien
que de cerises en vous taisez vous j'ai
la parole et trois fois dans l'émission
donc ma mère dépasse retourner moi je ne
veux plus voir à gauche il n'a pas
encore chez nous le dow jones g par un
garrot qu'elle a fait un single
[Applaudissements]
avec des gens comme vous c'est dix fois
qu'il faut se retourner que vous avez
dit c'est inadmissible parce que ces
deux chanteuses peut-être vous ne
l'aimez pas mais elle a été humiliée
elle a été traînée dans la boue vous
allez défendre ça c'est impossible ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est dégueulasse et
exceptionnellement un retournement a été
vexé parce qu'elle a pas une ride et
c'est tout généralement donné gamme
immense artiste de leurs maux vous êtes
qui vous agréent documentaire moisi mais
on peut pas non plus le critiquer mais
j'ai été
mais faudrait mais vous avec le champion
du monde de la connerie permis quand
s'arrêter arrêtés souvent d'être dans le
business vous mentez
[Musique]